gonna pull this tweet real quick we've
got this from Colin rugg he says Matt
Gates says Republicans will release 14
000 hours of January 6 tapes that were
hidden by democrats gates for the win
once again
what could be on these tapes and do you
think it's going to happen
I think it has a potential of happening
but I don't I'm not super positive just
because of everything that was supposed
to come out hasn't come out I mean I
actually talked to Gates in a Twitter
space last night I asked him about the
same thing and you know he was very
positive about it he seemed you know and
basically assured that these were going
to be released I mean I've seen a good
majority of this footage that's been
unreleased I wish I could talk about it
more but I can't but I mean they've
deleted footage they've they've scrubbed
through this so I mean even what you're
going to see if they do release this 14
000 hours of footage they're not going
to actually solve it they've deleted
some of it I mean they've said in public
statements that there was no video
camera where in the hallway where Ashley
Babbitt was shot there was multiple
video cameras I saw them myself multiple
congressmen can attest to actually
seeing the video cameras they're there
right now outside the speaker's lobby
but they don't want to release the other
angles of Ashley we have it being shot
because it shows Michael bird cowardly
hiding directly behind the barrier not
issuing a verbal warning not doing
anything and then stepping forward and
essentially executing Ashley wow what
happened she climbed up on a like a
piece of furniture or something to get
through a window and they just thought
she was attacking them well so so what
what happened is you had multiple
officers standing basically guarding
those doors and me and Ashley were the
very first ones to get into that room
and I actually you know I offered
officer yetter that was his name a water
bottle because he was covered in capacin
powder and you know they said no you
know it's fine um and Ashley Babbitt was
literally joking with the same officers
that moved out of the way of the barrier
uh you know minutes prior to her being
shot and that's the side of the story
you never hear but these cops the cert
team which Michael Berg claims wasn't
there that's the reason why he shot
Ashley Babbitt they were there they were
walking up the stairs and for those of
people that don't know about the surf
team it's basically the Tactical Team
for the capital you can see it on video
yeah you can see it on video and that's
that's you know where people like see
the thumbs up is because they didn't
realize when Michael bird stepped
forward and shot they didn't realize if
it was a friendly or not that had fired
that shot because it was so unexpected I
mean the cert team was in the room with
Babbitt and everyone else and you
actually right before she is shot and
killed and goes to the window she grabs
Zachary along with her right hand and
punches him in the face knocking his
glasses off and Zachary Alon was the one
that was responsible for breaking all
the barriers out so she goes through the
window basically in order to try and
stop the crowd I mean she was on camera
and on audio basically yelling at these
officers to do their job multiple times
and then they didn't do their job they
shifted over certain team comes to
replace and now the video I mean the
windows are completely exposed so they
think people are saying she was going to
get up and turn around and yell at the
crowd like hey cut it out kind of thing
you got it you got to think though I
mean she's 14-year Air Force veteran
she's been on multiple combat
deployments she knows what the rules of
engagement are right and you know is it
easier to stop an Angry Crowd or at
least a few angry people within the
crowd when you're on the same side of
the barrier with her or when you're on
the opposite side of the barrier and you
know logic says on the opposite side of
the barrier you can push people out the
window you can stand there you can guard
the window or you can at least grab that
window pane that's exposed and pull it
back in have they filed a wrongful death
suit I'm not sure if it's been
officially filed but I do know something
is in the process and it's also
important to note that that officer was
acting extremely Reckless to shoot an
unarmed woman in it was in in the neck
or in the face it was in the left
anterior shoulder yeah with you know
police officers behind her yeah and her
or not being armed is is absolutely
something that that should have been
National headline news there should have
been some larger accountability here but
this officer was investigated and not
even held accountable for for his crimes
meanwhile this was the same officer that
left a firearm in a public bathroom
before yeah in 2018 left his loaded
Glock in a uh public bathroom and a
civilian found it in the capital and
then you know his quote is actually
hilarious is he was Lieutenant at the
time he said I will not be punished uh
he says I will be treated differently
because of my rank as Lieutenant so I
mean if he actually was de-ranked or
actually punished with how he was
supposed to be in a proper law
enforcement scenario he wouldn't have
been there to shoot Ashley Babbitt I
mean it would have been somebody that
was leading the house security other
than Michael Burt I'm just thinking
about I mean you were there right and
you're you're a reporter or you're
covering what's going on how close how
close were you I mean was it were you in
danger yeah absolutely I mean not from
the uh the direct round I mean I was
closest to Michael bird out of anybody I
mean that's where you get like the hoax
of where oh he's on video giving her a
verbal warning but he didn't give her a
single verbal warning before he stepped
forward and shot her most people didn't
even realize that he was there it was so
loud in that room because you had a
crowd surge coming in from behind and
just overfilling and I mean like you had
John Sullivan which we all know about
John Sullivan he was right next to me he
has the angle of him actually shooting
Ashley and my angle is of Ashley falling
out the window and you know he's
screaming hey he's got a gun because
he's the only one that can see Michael
Burt and so I I remember I started
screaming it but you literally can't
hear from me to you and the distance
between me and Ashley was about I mean
for for me and surge you know 10 15 feet
and that's when I mean she went up
nobody even realized that there was a
gun there and he stepped forward and
executed her wow
that's absolutely just you know crazy
and insane yeah I never you know in all
my years reporting I mean I covered the
2020 riots um you know I've seen some
pretty crazy things you know the feet on
fire Molotov Clips all of those kinds of
things we were there I mean yeah in
Portland
there was also that one in uh during the
DNC in Philadelphia yeah I think Mike
turnovich was down there too yeah and we
saw something yeah I mean I've seen some
really crazy things on the ground but I
mean I've never seen nothing will ever
compare to what I experienced on January
6 and of course it still lives with me
seeing an innocent woman basically get
murdered by the government in front of
me and then I remember that night really
just I mean I was in shock I remember
stumbling out of the capital not really
understanding what took place
um I went you know I went to the hotel
they basically did a little mini martial
law you couldn't even leave your hotel
afterwards and you know I was lucky
enough to stay with some of the Infowars
guys they brought me in because my hotel
was on the opposite side of the entire
town and you couldn't even walk outside
and I remember watching the TV and you
know I had licensed my footage but I
didn't feel right about making an actual
profit offer I gave it to these news
sources for like two dollars a clip
um and then you got John Sullivan
selling it for 85 000 which is absurd so
yeah he got criminally charged but and
then now he's perfectly fine living in
Utah doing the joints charges or what
I'm pretty sure they dropped the charges
I'm not 100 sure but there's it's
suspicious around him the FBI reached
out to me uh after the shooting and the
only thing they wanted to talk about
they didn't want to talk about literally
anything else other than John Sullivan
so that kind of puts it into perspective
they want to talk about their little uh
their little Patsy toy but you know the
night of I just watched on the news
they're using my footage and spinning a
completely different story on what
happened they didn't talk about how
Ashley was trying to de-escalate instead
she was called a violent terrorist and
insurrectionist so that's kind of when
it set in for me of like I'm in the
middle of a cover-up as Ray Epps is on
you know camera on January 5th saying
we're gonna storm the capital and on
January 5th and then and then people
calling him a Fed people were screaming
fed fed fed and then he did the same
thing the next day yep he did the same
thing multiple times and is on camera
multiple times on the sixth organizing
people at different points saying we're
going into the capital and this is a man
that still has not been punished or even
brought in for questioning isn't that
correct yeah well he was brought in for
questioning by the January 6 committee
which is convenient because the
committee I literally begged them to
tell my story I wanted to tell my story
to them reached out on multiple accounts
none of them wanted to talk to me they
refused which now we know why I mean I
saw something I wasn't supposed to see
on multiple occasions but I mean then
you got Ray Epps and he is basically
being paraded around as the darling of
the day by Adam Kissinger and Liz Cheney
saying oh no he did nothing wrong even
though he is on video arguably doing
more than almost everybody that's
actually been prosecuted and sitting in
a Cell right it's crazy the raps thing
is the most agree like it's the one
where I hear about it I'm like oh I hear
this guy raps and then you see the video
of him and you hear his voice saying
let's go do this now like he's telling
people how is that guy not in some sort
of attention at the moment or excitement
like that that's the he orchestrated it
yep
did a whole lot more to get people riled
up than Donald Trump did that's right
well in Donald Trump's life we're going
to be peaceful We're the Party of Law
and Order don't forget right happens is
like a go do it yep and I built a
timeline uh directly after the six and
literally the first breach that happened
at the Capitol it was 19 minutes uh
Trump had 19 minutes left in his speech
so you can't really say that Trump was
the one who decided it it was Ray Epps
that literally formed that initial group
that I followed to the Capitol all of
the all of the people that say that
Trump incited Etc that is all garbage
like you can say that Trump didn't do
enough to
to quell it and calm them down and at
least I'll say I think that I might
disagree but at least that resembles the
reality that I experienced when people
say he intended to do it he was getting
people riled up the day before and et
cetera et cetera
he did not go there and tell people to
attack the capital he was not telling
people that they needed to go in blah
blah blah blah he was definitely you
know I mean he wanted to be president
still and he was looking for any any
excuse to stay enough can you blame him
though no I mean I get it I I get it
there there was there was a lot of
things that he had to be
irritated and and unsatisfied
dissatisfied with about the about the
election and leading up to it I I
absolutely believe that but you know he
didn't it wasn't an Insurrection at all
that's why I charge with insurance
that's why exactly that's why people how
are you going to over control government
with no firearms there is no there and
and there was there was never going to
be an a situation where Donald Trump
actually walked away in charge like that
wasn't in the car and how does it make
sense is you're you're just disrupting
this proceeding even if you somehow take
over the capital it's not how the US
government works right like you can take
over a government building you can squat
there nothing is going to come from that
there's still I mean there's checks and
balances everything that is in place to
make it not possible yeah it used to be
used to be that if you took a building
that's where the paperwork was and they
didn't know who was signed up for what
then you ran the show but now it's all
digital well I've always said I've said
this since day one is you know like I've
reported on a lot of a lot of violence
and a lot of things in my career but you
don't walk into one of the most secure
buildings in the the world unarmed
unless you're allowed to and they're on
video I mean it's literally on video cop
saying hey I don't agree with you but
come on in thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time